c'était donc le premier volet de ce
documentaire le célibat des prêtres le
calvaire de l'église la seconde partie
de ce film fera l'objet d'un autre débat
doc une enquête fouillée vous venez de
le voir réaliser dans 8 pays et trois
continents par Rémi Benichou et Éric
Colomer avec ce constat qu'il soit
hétérosexuel ou homosexuel la majorité
des clercs ne respecte plus la
discipline du célibat quelles
conséquence dès lors au sein de l'Église
catholique et bien nous allons en
débattre maintenant sur ce plateau avec
nos invités Eric Colomer et parmi nous
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
réalisateur et producteur de
documentaires et c'est donc vous qui
avez consigné ce film que nous venons de
voir avec
Rémi Benichou c'est combien de temps
d'enquête ce film c'est environ deux ans
de travail deux ans de travail et
pourquoi avoir choisi ce thème du
célibat des prêtres
parce que ça s'inscrit dans un une
continuité de travail j'ai produit
précédemment un documentaire qui
s'intitulait religieuse abusées qu'on a
eu le plaisir de présenter dans cette
même émission d'ailleurs absolument
l'autre scandale de l'église
et il me semblait intéressant de
poursuivre un travail
d'examen de l'état de l'Église
catholique en ce début de 21ème siècle
parce que la question du célibat me
paraissait être un point extrêmement
important pour examiner l'inertie de
l'église où son mouvement et les débats
qu'il agite objectif
réussi à avoir eu ce film après ce
formidable documentaire et cette
formidable enquête sur laquelle on va
revenir on va y revenir avec marcassier
bonjour bienvenue vous a découvert vous
votre parcours dans ce film vous étiez
prêt à être depuis 2004 au début du
tournage de ce documentaire vous êtes
tombé amoureux on l'a vu de l'une de vos
paroissiennes Ingrid avec qui vous avez
décidé de vivre tout simplement vous
avez été depuis suspendu par votre
évêque suspendu également par l'Institut
catholique de Paris vous avez travaillé
comme enseignant autrement dit vous êtes
toujours prêtes mais vous n'avez plus le
droit d'officier c'est bien ça
canoniquement je suis toujours prête
selon le droit de l'église je suis
toujours prête mais je n'ai pas le droit
d'officier en raison de mon état de vie
de
ce compagnonnage avec avec ma compagne
alors jusqu'à tout récemment vous avez
pointé à Pôle emploi comme tout à chacun
qui cherche du travail et aujourd'hui
vous vous lancez vous dans une
entreprise c'est pour ça j'ai créé ma
propre entreprise avec deux associés ou
je travaille sur les relations dans le
monde du travail voilà donc j'essaye
d'être un peu en continuité et bah bon
courage pour cette nouvelle vie
professionnelle mais on va surtout
revenir avec vous évidemment sur
ce que vous avez vécu au sein de
l'Église catholique jocelynin tricot est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
sociologue spécialisé en sociologie du
genre et des sexualités sociologiques du
catholicisme et ét politique des
masculinités vous avez participé aux
recherches de l'Inserm pour le compte de
la commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église et vous êtes
l'auteur de des soutanes et des hommes
votre travail de thèse publié au presse
universitaire de France une fois n'est
pas coutume je vous propose de commencer
par un extrait de votre documentaire pas
de ce premier volet que nous venons de
diffuser mais du second volet il s'agit
de sœur Marie-Paule rose qui est
sexologue
psychothérapeute et que vous avez
interviewé à l'occasion de votre enquête
on l'écoute
moi j'ai travaillé dans 33 pays le
célibat c'est simplement un emballage
pour changer la vision du monde pour que
les gens croient mon doute chez vous mon
doux que c'est beau l'emballage est beau
mais la réalité est pas là le mot qui me
vient c'est une farce là pourtant dans
l'église on se pose des grosses
questions
le cinéma des prêtres est-ce qu'on doit
l'exiger commencer par vous rendre
compte qu'il se vit pas sœur Marie-Paule
rose sexologue psychothérapeute et
religieuse et qu'on aura l'occasion
d'écouter et de réécouter à l'occasion
de la diffusion du deuxième volet de
votre film ce qui frappe surtout dans
votre enquête c'est sans doute pas le
non respect du célibat des prêtres on se
doutait bien qu'il y avait quelques
trous dans la raquette mais c'est
l'ampleur du phénomène est-ce que ça
vous avoue même surpris
oui l'ampleur de ce non-respect du
célibat du prêtre au sein de l'Église
catholique oui plutôt surpris c'est
effectivement pas une surprise que de
constater vérifier que
certains prêtres ne respectent pas
l'injonction de célibat voire deux
chasteté le bon sens populaire la
deviner il y a longtemps Annie Cordy
chantait déjà je suis la bonne du curé
dans les années 60 beaucoup de gens ont
compris que de demander à un homme de ne
pas avoir de sentiments
de rapport charnel de liaison amoureuse
et probablement une contrainte trop
forte pour pouvoir être tenue jusqu'à
présent les chiffres étaient difficiles
à appréhender mais on est au 21ème
siècle qu'on vient d'entendre vous dit
que selon elle il y aurait il n'y aurait
que 5% des prêtres et ça qui
respecterait
elle a fait une ah non elle a fait une
thèse de doctorat
supervisée dans une
université
au Canada et elle s'est appuyée sur des
échantillons témoins de prêtres qui sont
restés anonymes sur les cinq continents
et donc ce chiffre-là elle ne le tire
pas de nulle part c'est un travail de
thèse c'est un travail scientifique et
il est documenté et puis d'autres
sources
aujourd'hui vous diriez après avoir fait
cette enquête
on a affaire une vaste hypocrisie une
vaste comédie dit votre compagnie Ingrid
quelque part dans ce film une vaste
farce comme il vient d'être dit ici
c'est une farce d'un point de vue
politique je dirais c'est-à-dire
l'église maintient une règle qui n'est
pas tenable et et fait semblant de faire
croire qu'elle pourrait être tenable et
c'est dans ce sens que c'est une farce
en fait alors vous vous l'avez vécu de
l'intérieur
15 ans d'abstinence
les 15 premières années où vous avez été
prêtes comment vous l'avez vécu ce
célibat ça a été vous l'avez vu comme
une souffrance réellement une souffrance
que je ne me disais pas certainement
c'est à dire je cherchais un
accomplissement donc je me suis
usé dans le travail intellectuel j'ai
fait une thèse de doctoratologie je me
suis dit à un moment donné peut-être
qu'il faut que tu partes au bout du
monde missionnaire peut-être que c'est
ça l'accomplissement jusqu'à finalement
me retrouver comme homme et me dire mais
je me suis retrouvé comme homme grâce à
la rencontre d'Ingrid qui vient me
révéler mon humanité qui va me dire mais
tu as le droit d'être un homme tu n'es
pas un personnage hors sol sacré qui n'a
pas le droit d'avoir cette relation
d'amour avec avec une femme et donc elle
m'y autorise finalement vous avez étant
donné prêtre à l'âge de 27 ans
permettez-moi cette question est-ce que
vous avez eu des relations affectives
des relations sexuelles bien sûr avant
d'être ordonnée oui bien sûr et mais ce
qu'il y a c'est que quand on rentre au
séminaire
bien on va finalement mettre ça sous le
tapis au prétexte de l'idéal et on va le
défendre l'idéal moi de mes premières
années le ministère je défends l'idéal
du célibat et finalement c'est c'est en
avançant dans la vie que on se
redécouvre et on se dit mais mon
humanité complète elle est faite de mon
affectivité de ma sexualité de toute mon
humanité et c'est ça qui rendrait
certainement le prêtre
peut-être plus plus beau que ce qu'il
n'apparaît aujourd'hui quoi est-ce que
vous avez l'occasion pendant ces 15
années d'abstinence d'évoquer le sujet
avec avec vos confrères vos collègues
prêtres et dans les années qu'on suivi
celle où vous avez commencé à rencontrer
Ingrid c'est un sujet caché c'est un
sujet qui est sans cesse mis sous le
tapis moi quand je révèle ça à mon
supérieur hiérarchique à mon évêque et
puis il y a le vicaire général son
adjoint qui vient me voir je lui dis
écoute est-ce que on serait chiche de
nos sujets de sexualité d'affectivité
sur la table on se dit frère frère
prêtre allons-y parlons-en parlons-en et
j'ai toujours pas eu de réponse positive
à cela est-ce que l'ampleur du phénomène
vous assureprit vous le connaissiez déjà
alors et comment on explique parce que
fondamentalement c'est ça pour
travailler sur la question depuis
longtemps l'ampleur du phénomène me
surprend pas du tout alors la difficulté
c'est quand même de le mesurer est-ce
que c'est 50% est-ce que c'est plus et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire de rompre le
célibat on sait que ça peut aller de la
masturbation qui est déjà considéré
comme une rupture de ce de cet
engagement à une vie commune avec une
personne ou femme ou un coup d'un soir
évidemment ça a pas la même porte c'est
à dire que quand un évêque accompagne
ses prêtres il sait très bien que ça
peut être un coup du soir et puis on
repart voilà en tout cas tout ça met en
vous disiez que c'était une farce
pendant la soeur rose disait c'est aussi
parfois une tragédie pour les personnes
parce que l'idéal est tellement haut que
la culpabilité est d'autant plus forte
quand on met un coup de canif dans le
contrat comme m'avait dit un de mes
enquêter prête à ce sujet voilà ce qui
est dit dans ce film aussi c'est que les
prêtres concernés
peut-être l'état de schizophrénie dans
lequel peut le mettre cette célibat
imposée oui et cette schizophrénie est
d'autant plus puissante aujourd'hui que
les individus prêts sont pris entre
quelque part leur engagement à être la
façade de l'église à l'incarner face à
leur fidèle mais aussi face aux
non-croyants qui peuvent les interroger
on sait que le célibat c'est finalement
c'est le l'outil qui permet de
surprendre si cette question est là
aujourd'hui
sur la Chaîne Parlementaire c'est que ça
surprend que des gens s'engagent aussi
libre donc cette nécessité c'est
engagement être la façade
institutionnelle de l'église et en c'est
injonction toute moderne à
l'authenticité à s'écouter soi etc et
qui met en difficulté les individus qui
sont pris entre ces deux ces deux
injonctions et question de béotien
lorsqu'on est Rabat on peut se marier
avoir des enfants lorsqu'on est imam on
peut se marier on peut avoir des enfants
lorsqu'on est prêt dans l'église
protestante on peut se marier oui voilà
même dans l'Église catholique romaine la
force société c'est de rappeler ce que
un certain nombre de catholiques
ignorent est-ce que l'Église ne redit
pas souvent c'est que même au sein de
l'Église catholique il y a des prêtres
mariés dans les Églises orientales mais
y compris dans l'église dit latine ou
occidentale Benoît XV et celui alors
même qu'il apparaît comme
classique c'est celui qui a quand même
ordonné des anciens pasteurs et évêques
en gliquant
avec femme et enfant
tout simplement parce qu'il quittaient
l'église anglicane qui orgue donné à ce
moment-là des femmes ce qui est
intéressant et donc voilà ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que l'Église a aussi
les moyens de transformer célibat de le
modifier de le libéraliser c'est-à-dire
de faire que ce qu'ils veulent le
choisir le choisir c'est ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas le choisir le choisissent
pas sauf que ce célibat est aujourd'hui
et rigé en espèce de totem d’identité
par un certain nombre de catholiques qui
le mettent comme comme au-dessus de
certains dogmes de vérité révélés ça
devient la signature catholique par
rapport aux autres églises en fait alors
il y a un autre totem
dans au sein de l'Église catholique
c'est l'homosexualité et là aussi vous
brisez un tabou à travers votre enquête
on va écouter votre collègue italien
Marco Marzano sa nouvelle extrait du
documentaire
ce soir les homosexuels sont partout
dans l'église et en nombre très
important
certains sont allés jusqu'à dire que la
majorité des prêtres sont homosexuels
c'est non
mais répétez que le clergé homosexuel
est une réalité
l'Église catholique serait même année un
espace privilégié pour les homosexuels
on apprend cela aussi dans votre
documentaire or on rappelle tout de même
et c'est rappelé aussi dans ce film que
l'Église condamne l'homosexualité
l'Église catholique condamne aujourd'hui
l'homosexualité là vous mettez le doigt
sur un paradoxe formidable et et vous
nous révéler aussi l'ampleur de
l'homosexualité au sein de cette église
catholique ça vous a surpris ou quand
cette enquête aussi pour le coup oui
il est paraissait évident que dans
l'Église comme ailleurs dans la société
il puisse y avoir des personnes
homosexuelles ou hétérosexuels mais
est-ce que ce sociologue italien nous
apprend et ce que nous comprennent aussi
Peter revolvant qui sont
deux anciens claires
qui ont quitté l'église catholique pour
rejoindre le protestantisme aujourd'hui
en Allemagne en Allemagne donc c'est que
l'Église catholique a constitué pendant
très longtemps et jusqu'à peu refuge
aussi pour les homosexuels cette analyse
est intéressante elle nous raconte que
dans une société où l'homosexualité
peut-être
a été récusé montrer du doigt discriminé
se retrouver prêtre et célibataire
ça permettait d'avoir des relations et
ça permet encore d'avoir des relations
homosexuelles cachées sans avoir à se
justifier sur son statut de célibat mais
pourquoi n'as-tu pas d'enfants pourquoi
n'as-tu pas de femmes ça permet d'éviter
d'avoir à répondre à ces questions là il
est naturel d'être un homme seul dans
l'église et du coup d'avoir une double
vie et une double vie homosexuelle
qu'il était très difficile d'assumer
auprès de sa famille de la société et de
son entourage vous avez une idée vous de
l'ampleur
de l'homosexualité au sein de l'Église
catholique à travers vos études alors
encore une fois les chiffres sont
compliqués à obtenir puisque c'est un
tabou c'est l'éléphant dans la pierre de
l'église la question de l'éléphant dans
la pièce ah c'est l'éléphant dans la
pièce maintenant que les violences
sexuelles sont sur le la place publique
qui reste ce tabou là
totem est à bout une petite allusion à
Fred
les chiffres qu'on a quand les enquêtes
un peu indirect c'est entre 30 et 70%
voire peut-être plus
ça dépend des endroits etc mais c'est
évident
pardon c'est un une grosse partie de mon
travail de thèse c'est c'est clairement
la solution pour un jeune homme qui naît
dans le catholicisme pétri de cette
idéale voyant le prêtre aussi comme
cette surhomme qui est valorisé c'est la
solution solution pour pour
échapper au mariage hétérosexuel et on
comprend aussi pourquoi l'Église c'est
profondément énervé contre le mariage
pour tous comme me le dire de mes
enquêter sous la forme de la blague mais
quand même ça dit quelque chose c'est
que le mariage pour tous si ça passait
et si ça passe dans les mœurs
catholiques c'est l'assurance de vider
les séminaires qui sont déjà largement
vides d'autant plus que les
hétérosexuels n'ont plus beaucoup
d'intérêt aujourd'hui à rentrer dans la
prêtrice depuis que l'Église a
revalorisé voir survalorisé
la sexualité au sein de du couple
hétérosexuel et comment elles en
explique qu'il puisse y avoir entre 50
et 70% pour reprendre votre fourchette
d'homosexuel dans l'Église catholique et
que néanmoins l'église continue à
condamner l'homosexualité
ça leur est incompréhensible pour
peut-être un certain nombre de gens qui
nous regardent encore une fois en la
normalisant d'abord l'église n'est pas
la seule institution à avoir
pathologisé
criminaliser l'homosexualité c'est assez
récent dans les années 80 on commence
sexualité déviante selon l'Église
catholique alors oui quand elle est
pratiquée
elle l'est pas et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que l'Église demande
exactement la même chose homosexuel
qu'au prêtre c'est à dire l'abstinence
oui enfin c'est en constatant je
voudrais dire l'ampleur de
l'homosexualité dans l'église en le
vivant de l'intérieur et c'est aussi ce
que vous avez constaté est-ce que je
constate est-ce que je vois de plus en
plus et d'ailleurs le jour où je vais
voir mon évêque pour lui dire je vais
quitter l'institution parce que je suis
amoureux je lui dis mais mais vous
pouvez pas ignorer
l'ampleur des relations amoureuses
homosexuelles de de mes confrères et
c'est ça que je veux mettre sur la table
d'ailleurs et et c'est ça qu'on me
refuse c'est pas tant de mettre ma
relation à moi sur la table c'est celle
de mes confrères homosexuels qui sont
comme dit jocelynin tricou placardisé
dans l'église donc c'est pour moi c'est
aussi une souffrance que de voir des
hommes ne pas pouvoir vivre en cohérence
finalement avec
leur orientation ce qu'ils veulent vivre
et ne pas pouvoir voilà aller jusqu'au
bout peut-être pour compléter juste dire
que tant que l'Église pardon tant que la
société était homophobe finalement
l'église et c'est une sorte dommage
qu'on peut lui rendre paradoxal elle
n'accepterait pas a été ce refuge aussi
pour ces personnes stigmatisées par
ailleurs sauf qu'aujourd'hui la société
est en train de normaliser normalement
l'homosexualité du coup l'église se
retrouve elle obligée à rendre son
homophobie visible voire agressive
ça donne des dizaines de milliers de
gens dans la rue contre les et les
lesbiennes
et c'est là où le placard qui était
l'église est entre entre en crise avec
aujourd'hui on constate des prêtres qui
quittent non plus pour des femmes qui
étaient la réalité assez banale des
années 70 mais des prêtres qui pour des
hommes évidemment c'est compliqué on
voit bien y compris au sein du clergé
quand on parle avec en privé des gens
qui disent mais c'est plus un problème
sauf que on a tellement
poussé les fidèles à
être homophobe que c'est il faut faire
marcher une arrière quoi c'est compliqué
et on assiste à un croisement
c'est-à-dire que ces prêtres homosexuels
qui quittent l'Église catholique parce
que
ils n'ont pas leur place sont remplacés
par faisant parliez tout à l'heure des
prêtres mariés avec enfants qui viennent
de l'Église
orthodoxe maronite caldéenne protestante
anglicane et qui eux quitte leur église
parce que il considère que leur église
anglican par exemple un Angleterre et
trop progressiste parce qu'elle autorise
le mariage homosexuel par exemple donc
c'est prêtre marié hétérosexuels voient
notre mauvaise oeil la libéralisation la
modernisation de leur église et
rejoignent l'Église catholique
considérée par eux comme un lieu
conservateur ou seuls l'hétérosexualité
est admissible et où l'homosexualité
serait toujours et encore contre nature
alors dans votre enquête vous êtes aussi
intéressé aux compagnes des prêtres et
aussi aux enfants des prêtres on va
écouter Isabelle balestrauss et on en
parle juste après
quand on est dans l'intimité
[Musique]
Isabelle par mon prénom
il parle de moi oui en disant que
j'étais sa fille mais dès qu'on était
dans la rue j'avais l'interdiction de
l'approcher si parler de personnes qui
rencontraient c'était quand même très
difficile pour moi de devoir me cacher
qu'il ne fallait pas que ces
personnes-là sachent que j'étais sa
fille il m'appelait il disait que
j'étais sa fille
souffrance d'une fille de prêtre en
l'occurrence Isabelle balestros on
l'apprend au tout début du film vous
êtes le petit-fils d'un prêtre et d'une
religieuse vous êtes donc directement
concerné par la souffrance qui a pu
ressentir Isabelle balais Strauss par
exemple oui c'est celle que vous pouvez
en dire ce statut finalement c'est le
poids c'est le poids du secret c'est le
poids du silence que l'Église finalement
impose assez à ses enfants de ne pas
pouvoir assumer publiquement cette
relation avec un père et une mère et
voilà moi j'en suis un peu comme
j'ai reçu par une transmission
intergénérationnelle ce poids là et
là on fait face à nouveau à cette
culture du silence de l'église qui
impose finalement le secret de toutes
ces situations vous avez
participé concouru j'imagine à
l'éducation des enfants de votre
compagne et Ingrid qui qui a 5 enfants
on l'a appris dans ce film et vous étiez
encore prêt à être à l'époque
et ben ça ça met les pieds sur terre je
voudrais dire c'est c'est une manière de
et c'est là que je pense que l'Église se
trompe complètement en se réfugiant
derrière un dogme complètement vétuste
c'est-à-dire que le prêtre avec des
enfants et bien il touche à des réalités
bien concrètes avec une compagne et
touche à des réalités bien concrètes il
baptise il m'arrive ça serait peut-être
plus incarné on va dire de baptiser de
célébrer à partir de cette expérience
que sans cette expérience alors là aussi
pour reprendre une expression vous avez
utilisé tout à l'heure on met tout ça
sous le tapis on accepte du côté de
l'église catholique qu'il y a un père de
substitution ou alors ou alors on
accepte aussi de donner une somme
d'argent au maire pour garder le silence
voilà c'est ça les sont sales les
solutions qui sont présentées dans ce
documentaire
par exemple aux États-Unis où on payait
en échange d'une clause de
confidentialité
la question de la sauvegarde de l'image
de l'institution était première et c'est
là où l'effondrement actuel est d'autant
plus violente que c'est choquant
c'est-à-dire que l'Église qui s'est
longtemps permis
de donner des leçons de bonnes moralité
de défense des enfants puisque c'était
aussi un des arguments contre le mariage
des personnes de même sexe
se retrouve elle-même prise à son propre
piège prise aux propres pièges de son
discours
et en plus dans une logique encore une
fois toute moderne d'authenticité ça
rend c'est les individus qui sont censés
incarner
comme des donneurs de leçons qui faites
ce que je dis faites pas ce que je fais
et il va falloir travailler pour
regagner sans doute de la part
d'institution c'est de confiance avec
beaucoup d'humilité et beaucoup de
prises en compte de ces réalités
complexes plutôt que de les mettre sous
le tapis ces arrangements indignes
ce qui aujourd'hui nous renseigne sur le
niveau de non acceptabilité de ses
arrangements c'est le fait que à
l'intérieur de l'église aujourd'hui le
plus en plus de membres de l'Église et
de Claire en particulier ne les supporte
plus n'en veuille plus c'est à dire ne
veuille plus s'accommoder de double vie
de campagne cachées d'enfants
abandonnés en quelque sorte
ça c'est un bon signe ça dit que il y a
un niveau de conscience dans la dans
l'église alors pas forcément au niveau
de la hiérarchie du Vatican ou de Rome
mais en tout cas dans l'église vivante
celle qui est animée par par des gens
d'église par des clercs un refus
désormais de plus en plus grand
d'accepter ses arrangements cette
hypocrisie et ses souffrances imposées
prêtre à la campagne à leurs enfants
malheureusement pardon je complète
malheureusement il a fallu attendre en
tout cas en France
la crise liée aux violences sexuelles
aux révélations autour des violences
sexuelles le travail
douloureux pour les victimes de la
science pour qu'un certain nombre de
catholiques y compris des cas de
rappeler c'est la commission
indépendante sur les abus sexuels dans
l'église pour que les catholique voilà
je l'ai précisé tout à fait de votre
présentation et pour que des catholiques
y compris des catholiques très fervents
très observant face se repose la
question par exemple du célibat des
prêtres qui est une question en fait
qui date des catholiques progressistes
de gauche des années 60-70 et qui était
vu comme une question ringarde de vieux
schnock etc on va parler du du rapport
sauvé et donc de la science de cette
fameuse commission indépendante qui a
été chargée de faire un diagnostic
depuis 1950 les chiffres là aussi sont
assez possible là je rappelle les 216
000 victimes d'abus sexuels répertoriés
depuis 1950 en France au vu de ce
rapport 330 000 si on y ajoute les abus
sexuels venus du personnel laïque qui
participe à la vie de l'institution
catholique les professeurs de catéchisme
les bénévoles les mouvements de jeunesse
80% de ses victimes sont de jeunes
garçons et là on parle de
pédocriminalité vous n'abordez
évidemment pas ce sujet dans votre film
néanmoins moi il y a une question qui se
pose c'est est-ce qu'on peut trouver une
corrélation entre le non-respect ou
l'imposition du célibat auprès d'un
église catholique et
ces violences sexuelles c'est ZAC de
pédocriminalité constaté au sein de
l'Église catholique depuis maintenant de
très nombreuses années alors tous les
spécialistes accordent pour dire qu'on
ne peut pas faire de lien direct
néanmoins pour mettre entretenu au cours
des années passées avec des
psychanalyses des psychiatres des
psychologues certains considèrent que
cette obligation de célibat
a conduit des prêtres dès leur jeune âge
à la majorité quand la plupart d'entre
eux commencent leur séminaire dans une
situation d'immaturité
affective sentimentale sexuel que
fait-on quand on devient adolescent et
qu'on devient un jeune homme une jeune
femme on apprend l'altérité on apprend
le désir de l'autre les besoins de
l'autre les attentes de l'autre on
apprend à bâtir une relation faite sur
du désir qui est une relation
consentie
partagée quand on n'a pas appris ça
qu'on a fait un séminaire et qu'on est
devenu prêtre et qu'on n'a pas fait
l'expérience de l'autre et de sa
sexualité et qu'on se retrouve dans une
situation de pouvoir spirituel car c'est
bien de cela qu'il s'agit le prêtre
sacralisé autour de sur ces sujets c'est
à dire des fidèles les enfants des
femmes bref des gens qui sont très
croyants c'est un pouvoir spirituel
énorme et c'est donc une emprise
potentielle énorme donc ajoutons à cela
l'immaturité le pouvoir quand on libère
une pulsion comme se passe-t-il on
possède on se saisit
on a une emprise et on n'est plus dans
une relation consentie mais dans une
relation imposée c'est ce que d'aucun
d'aucune analyse comme liée un potentiel
entre le célibat d'un côté les violences
sexuelles de l'autre marque si vous avez
vu l'occasion de réfléchir à cette
question vous y voyez vous une
corrélation entre les deux et jusqu'à où
c'était que j'y vois la corrélation sur
l'action de l'abus de pouvoir c'est à
dire que l'abus sexuel à un moment donné
se fonde comme a pu voir égal à bussex
et c'est ça exactement parce que après
même s'il y a une pathologie de la
personne mais on donne un tel un tel
aura sacré finalement au prêtre qu'on
lui autorise et c'est là aussi on a
peut-être pas assez abordé sur le déni
collectif des fidèles c'est à dire on
donne finalement au prêtre un caractère
tellement sacré qu'on lui autorise tout
il est devenu finalement celui qui n'a
plus aucun interdit et ici en plus il y
a des pathologies chez cet homme et ben
on ne va directement des rives donc je
pense qu'à urgence à ce qu'on fasse
redescendre le prêt de ce piédestal
sacré si on veut éviter que on fasse une
sieste 2 dans 10 ans 20 ans je sais
quand et c'est là où on voit que le
célibat c'est pas seulement la question
du célibat c'est avec c'est la question
du refus de cette altérité des femmes de
cette altérité sexuelle que la question
de l'othéros sexualité etc c'est la
question aussi du refus d'accepter qu'on
exerce un pouvoir le pouvoir est
toujours codé dans l'Église catholique
comme un service et d'ailleurs ce
service il est rendu par quelqu'un qui
s'est lui-même sacrifié la sacrifié sa
sexualité en fait le célibat vient
marquer seulement ça cette espèce de
choses là et donc effectivement ça
produit des fidèles en incapacité de
voir chez le prêtre un homme et donc un
homme et donc un potentiel aussi abuseur
de pouvoir et on comprend aussi pourquoi
la sexualité est le terrain favorable
aux abus de pouvoir puisque c'est par la
sexualité qu'on rend légitime où il
légitime imprêtent c'est pas forcément
ses compétences professionnelles un
prêtre peut être très mauvais en homélie
c'est à dire en explication du texte
biblique il sera jamais viré il les viré
et où pousser à la sortie plus
exactement que si on sait publiquement
qu'il est dans une relation sexuelle
dernière petite chose aussi le célibat a
une définition tellement restrictive en
catholicisme que tout est mis sur le
même plan l'usage de la masturbation
l'usage de la sexualité avec un adulte
consentant comme l'usage de la sexualité
non consentante avec un enfant avec une
femme
donc pour ça un prêtre ne sait plus
faire la différence on va diffuser le
deuxième volet de votre documentaire
dans un dans une autre émission des
Badoc qu'est-ce qu'on va y découvrir
vous interrogez il y a-t-il un risque de
schisme vous avez jusqu'à cette
interrogation dans votre seconde partie
de documentaire ce cette célibat imposé
pourrait créer un schisme dans l'Église
catholique à terme ce qu'on constate en
tout cas c'est que le célibat imposé est
très largement responsable d'une fuite
des prêtres d'une crise d'évocation
l'église se vide et autour de cette
question du célibat obligatoire
s'affrontent de camps qu'on va nommer
progressiste et conservateur le Condé
conservateurs qui veut garder une figure
sacrée un pur esprit le prêtre pur
esprit qui doit rester célibataire et
les progressistes qui elles veulent le
ramener homme parmi les hommes
ce combat là aujourd'hui il est dans
certains territoires le plus en plus
manifeste c'est de plus en plus frontal
merci vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce premier volet consacré à
votre documentaire célibat les prêtres
le calvaire de l'église on va donc
découvrir le second volet de votre
travail dans une prochaine émission des
Badoc et on y abordera ces sujets à
l'occasion de cette émission vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
sur Twitter j'imagine qu'elle va être
nombreux je compte sur vous pour
répondre à ce que sont ces réactions
merci à sel massalik comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]